>>Somebody just take that.
>>Narrator: For most students,
technology is a tool that saves time
and helps them research,
explore, create.
>>Student: Get a little
bit of the tree.
>>Narrator: For disabled
students like Susanna Martini,
technology is all of those
things and much more.
It is a lifeline.
>>Susanna: Assistive technology is
the major foundation of my life.
Without it I could not
exist as I am today.
I mean without a computer
I couldn't do my homework.
>>Move left one word.
>>Without my chair I
couldn't get around.
Without my cell phone I
couldn't, you know, call for help.
>>Narrator: Active since she
was born with cerebral palsy,
Susanna refereed soccer matches
from her wheelchair in high school.
A sophomore at the University
of Washington she uses
voice activated software
to complete her written assignments.
>>Susanna: Because computers
involved electricity.
>>Sheryl: We all know how
technology has improved
in the last few years
all sorts of technology.
What most people don't realize
is that assistive technology,
technology that helps people
with disabilities use computers has
been progressing at the same rate.
>>Susanna: Answer, air pressure
prevents this from happening.
Source: Steven Hawking.
>>Sheryl: Even though there's a lot
of technology available for people
with disabilities, it
isn't implemented that much
in our school systems today and
there are a lot of reasons for that.
One is that people who work
with students with disabilities,
this could be teachers, lab
managers, parents, often aren't aware
of the technology that
is available for them
and then technology is not always
included in the planning process.
>>Susanna: Back in high
school they didn't understand
that I needed a laptop and I needed
a desk that could raise and lower
and I didn't have those things.
>>I got a laptop after my mom made
them get me one because she knows how
to get through the red tape but
it's really necessary for anybody
who has a disability to get what
they need assistive technology wise.
>>Teacher: So the elevator
controls what we call pitch.
>>Narrator: The University
of Washington's Disabilities
Opportunities Internet-working
and Technology program or DO-IT helps
students get the technology they need
and holds summer workshops to
help them prepare for college.
>>On this one, I agree
that you found the rule.
>>Vishal: I use my laptop that
I got from the DO-IT program
and I use on-screen keyboard to type
and to print and to surf the web.
>>Now I'm ready for
a bigger challenge.
>>Narrator: Vishal Saraiya
was elected President
of the Summit K through
12 student body.
>>I'm Vishal Saraiya and
I hope you vote for me.
>>Narrator: And is planning
to attend college next fall.
>>Sheryl: If they have access
to computers they can take their own
notes, they can take their own tests,
they can write their own
papers, they can use the Internet
and do their own research.
These are things that they
couldn't do in another way.
They need to practice
these independent skills
so that they can move on to
college and on to careers.
>>George: What was your favorite part
that you learned about--
okay, go ahead.
>>Student: The Northwest Indians.
>>Narrator: Studies show that the
earlier children are introduced
to assistive devices the
quicker they master them.
>>Carlos: This morning I was mad.
>>George: Why were you mad, Carlos?
>>Carlos: Because I
didn't want to get
up in the morning to go to school.
>>Narrator: So at Redwoods
Heights Elementary
in Oakland California the
learning begins in preschool.
>>George: By introducing
kids to technology early,
it gets them better prepared and
makes it easier down the road
and then they can spend the later
years of their school years focusing
on content material
and the curriculum.
>>Student: Bird.
>>George: Okay, what else?
>>Narrator: The first task is to
determine the best way for the child
to access a device whether it's
the touch of a finger, a nod,
or the twitch of an eyebrow.
>>George: It took us three
years to figure Adrian out,
he couldn't move any parts of
his body except his eye brow
and so we determined that
that was the switch site
and then we determined which
type of device would be used.
>>Teacher: First the
device scans the rows.
And then when he twitches
his eyebrow it begins
to select the column so
row, column scanning.
>>Narrator: The devices are
personalized with various icons,
phrases and voices and can be
programmed to let children share news
from home with their classmates
or tell their parents
what they did in school.
>>Student: We are learning
about the solar system.
>>Teacher: Where?
Which class?
That's right.
>>George: Can you name
some of the planets for us?
>>Student: Mars, Jupiter...
>>George: I think we give something
that's priceless, a voice basically.
>>Student: Pluto.
>>George: A lot of our kids are
bright and we give them that power.
Who knows the next one could
be the next great physicist.
Or next great scientist.
I mean we've got some wonderful
kids with some wonderful minds.
>>Narrator: For one student
at Spokane's Mead High
School technology is the key
to pursuing his passion.
>>Narrator: Lukas Bratcher
loves to play his Euphonium horn
in the school jazz band, concert
band, and even the marching band.
That Lukas can play anywhere is
a testament to his perseverance
and the support of many people who
help make his playing possible.
It has been an uphill battle ever
since he was born with a condition
that renders his limbs
nearly useless.
>>Lukas: It's called amyoplasia
arthrogryposis multiplex congenita
and it's throughout my four limbs
and it's basically I have stiffness
in my joints and some of
my muscles aren't there.
>>Teacher: What's another
name for one over sin-theta?
>>Lukas: Cosecant.
>>Teacher: Cosecant theta.
>>Narrator: Lukas hasn't let
his disability prevent him
from participating fully at school.
>>Teacher: That's one
over cosine theta.
>>Lukas: Right.
>>Narrator: He takes four
advanced placement classes.
And does his homework on
a laptop without the aid
of the voice recognition
software the school provided.
>>Lukas: How about we
move the knight there.
>>Narrator: Lacking manual dexterity,
Lukas learned to play music his
own special way to the amazement
of his first band director.
>>Lee: He looked very eager and
excited about being a member
of the band and quite
honestly my thought
at that time was oh my goodness,
how could this possibly work?
And as we took the students
through their method book I noticed
that occasionally he
would play on his horn.
His hands were not able to activate
the valves on the instrument
so it was apparent to me that what
he was doing was just being selective
about the notes that he was playing.
>>He was willing to just sit there
and just wait for that one note
to come along in the music and
when it came he played it with all
of his heart and enthusiasm
and capability
to make the best sound that he could.
That was enough for him, initially.
>>Narrator: But Lukas knew
he could do more and that's
when serendipity led his mother
to the instrument repair
shop of Robin Amend.
>>Robin: I love repairing.
It's always different.
You're always working on
a different instrument.
There's always different problems.
My grandfather was a
vaudeville musician.
He lost his arm in a
lumber mill accident.
He put an ad in the Portland
paper asking one-armed people
if they're interested
in learning music.
He taught them how
to play instruments.
>>Narrator: The senior Amend also
patented a device that allowed people
with missing hands to play the piano.
>>Robin: I'd always wished
that I could make something
that could make a person who had
lost an arm be able to take the place
of their fingers and then one night
I woke up in the middle of the night
and I realized that
joy sticks aren't just
for putting electrical
things on screens.
Joy sticks can do other things.
Joy sticks can do mechanical things.
>>Narrator: Amend's dream became
a small box with a joy stick
that triggered solenoids and
operated the valves of a horn.
Learning a new way of playing
was exhilarating and frustrating
for Lukas and just as
he was getting the hang
of playing it, someone took his horn.
>>TV Newscaster: Call Crimecheck
if you have any information.
>>Kristy: It was stolen in the
morning and by five o'clock
that same day I was getting
the first call on my cell phone
from an anonymous person
that said that they wanted
to contribute monetarily to a fund
to either replace it or as a reward
for it and from that point
on it just snowballed
into this huge wonderful thing where
the community raised 6,000 dollars.
>>Andrew: I wasn't quite
sure where the optimum spot
for the solenoids was going
to be so I want to be able
to have it slide up and down.
>>Narrator: The loss of the
first horn became a blessing
when mechanical engineer
Andrew Coleman joined Amend
to design a second more
responsive joystick
and horn which Lukas uses today.
>>Lee: When I heard and
saw Lukas perform recently
at a concert it reminded
me just how far we've come.
And through the efforts
of all the people
that have been supporting him
we caught on to his dream.
>>Sheryl: Technology has
changed all of our lives,
but for these students
technology truly changes their life
and the opportunities that
they'll have in the future.
>>Susanna: I think assistive
technology is going to allow me major
in communications and get a
minor in disabilities studies.
I actually want to be a news anchor.
>>I'm hoping to go to
college on a music scholarship
and study music an be a musician.
I love to play.
>>Narrator: For more
information on what works
in public education
go to edutopia.org.